I have the distinction
of having begun life twice
in my first version of life I was born
in southwest Philadelphia
in a family that had
eventually six children
my mother and father had menial work
jobs in the area and my grandmother who
lived in the house with us
ran the household and took care of the
chores in the house while my parents
worked
I was born in 1961 so I experienced a
lot of the developmental changes in the
city of Philadelphia throughout my
childhood
at first
we had the pleasure of being part of a
city that took pride in its
neighborhoods
having blocked captains and Gardens and
everyone made an effort to make their
part of Philadelphia beautiful
and then it all seemed to change during
the aftermath of the 1968 assassination
of Martin Luther King
I was seven years old
in a connective way
this was the most tumultuous year of my
life as well
because
I remember
[Music]
everything was still golden and
beautiful in my childhood
until the spring of 1968
when I was left off from school one day
because I had a dental appointment
my mother cautioning me to leave the
house and not ruin my school clothes
yelled her usual warnings to me
but I was off on an adventure with my
little dog Jocko a black poodle who
never left my side
and I went down to the local
wooded area behind my neighborhood back
behind 74th Street
and I encountered a young man
who is off from school himself older
than me by about 10 15 years
and
he was just I guess
in the moment
of whatever he was doing
I remember being very terrified of him
having seen him in the neighborhood
beating up adult men this is a very
violent chaotic person and
I timidly didn't know what to do
I was just a little boy
he was smoking a cigarette and he took
the cigarette out of his mouth and he
made me take a puff of the cigarette
I became intoxicated and lightheaded
from the inhale
as I choked and sputtered I felt him put
his hands on my neck and pushed me
backwards and knocked me to the ground
and then he hit me in the head with a
field stone that was in his hand
I only heard the wet smack of the stone
on flesh I didn't realize it was my head
the four state of low had done so much
damage
the next remembrance I have of that
occasion was
I was coming too and he was putting his
clothes right after having sexually
assaulted me
and
he was formulating some kind of plan
he either wanted me to not be a witness
or he was
thinking of what to do you could see it
in his face
and in a moment he started shouting at
me you tell your parents you were
pushing a shopping cart on that wall
over there you tell your parents that
your shopping cart fell over and hit you
and that's how you got that lump on your
head and when he said it I put my hand
up
and I had a massive
contusion on my head
I didn't say anything that I can
remember
I waited for him to leave
and I looked around for my dog and I
couldn't find Jocko and I started
screaming for him
I remember running up the street and the
lady on the on Wheeler Street saw me
and she oh my God look at you get home
boy get home
I made it up to my land Street where my
family lived at the time
and my mother looked at me and she said
oh my God I can't believe what happened
so I was taken to The Wills Eye Hospital
in Philadelphia
and I was diagnosed
um
with
my optic nerve damage to my eyes from
the swelling
and they had hoped that in time the
swelling would go down without damaging
it to the point that I would go blind
I don't know
seven years old
I had to wear corrective glasses after
that I went from being a left hand a
right-handed child to a left-handed
child
everything in my brain was scattered
I had night terrors and I remember
I would go down to my parents basement
and punch my legs
so that
I wouldn't be afraid of pain so that if
I went outside and he attacked me I
wouldn't be afraid
I started acting out
I remember when I was
early on
trying to deal with this
I would make a Fantastical stories for
my father at dinner about owning a farm
and I would tell them about these
tragedies on the farm
opening in some confused way I could
tell him what happened to me
I never did
once I told the LIE
and lived with the lie and I was bound
by the LIE
and I hated myself
when you let someone off the hook for
doing that to you you hate yourself
inside
for knowing that you're you're letting
them get away with it you're letting
them hurt you
I couldn't deal with it
I was at a family function when I was 10
years old and
I had my first bottle of Pabst Blue
Ribbon beer
and by the time I got done with that
beer I wasn't afraid anymore
I was like
oh
there's another side to dealing with
this
by the time I was 14 I was an alcoholic
with my friends on the weekends and
every night smoking pot drinking
then pills came along and they're very
popular with Quaaludes and
second all and two and all and Valium
and
I took every kind of pill because when I
was high
I had courage
to not be afraid not courage to fight
others I always
oh God I gravitated towards violence
but I I wasn't afraid inside I didn't
have this omnipresent fear
that there was something about me that
would make men want to do that to me
so I emulated all of the bad behaviors
that you can
becoming really aggressive really nasty
and I got hooked on methamphetamine
at the age of 18
I stole a car I went to Florida I threw
furniture out of a hotel room because I
lost my mind and I was put into the
south Florida State Mental Institution
for my own protection
it was there that I was diagnosed with
aphasia I had no clue what this meant
but the doctors actually did brain scans
on me and showed me
that I had a physiological distortment
to my cognitive process of language
and associative abilities to connect
with others because of this blockage
they explained to me that the one drug
that you didn't want to do
with speed because it evaporated any of
what they called the proteins that were
protecting my brain from going into
Aphasia shutdown
a lot of people have recently heard
about Aphasia because of Bruce Willis
but I'll explain what it is
have you ever woken
were just about woken from a nap
all around you are recognizable sounds
but you're lost to the dream state
you can't help it you
you want to break free of it but you're
stuck there
and you don't want to let go
imagine your whole day is stuck there
and you can't get out of it
that's what aphasia is
you have an awareness of what's going
around you but you're so deeply delved
into this other realm of consciousness
of either memory or reptitudes of songs
or all these things you can't break free
of it
I had to work so hard because my Aphasia
was so bad I would become monocited in
times of stress and I couldn't see out
of my left eye
and I would invariably sit with my thumb
pressed against my head like this
for as long as I could cut off the
pressure from the pain of my eye just
pounding and pounding
I was sober
everything was good
I came back to Philadelphia I had some
minor charges I was let go
I got a job at Spencer's Gifts in
downtown Philly
it's 20 years 19 years old 20 years old
for the first time since I was 14 years
old I was actually sober a little bit of
weed nothing else because I was afraid
of what they explained to me in that
hospital it really scared me
this is Cuban Doctor Who took a real
good time to explain to me exactly how
my brain was damaged and I still didn't
tell him why
I go back to Philly I get a job
I'm dating this girl named Terry
and she's working downtown in the center
city area Philly
and
I was doing okay for a couple months but
then I'm hanging out with everybody I'm
living in my parents house I'm fighting
with my brothers
everything's chaos again it's all the
dysfunction in my family pressurizing me
and I start doing meth
I bought a gram of meth and I started
getting high
and then sure enough
I want it more so I stole a car
I stole a car I drove down to see Terry
at her work
had something of hers I was going to
return
and I got stopped by the Philadelphia
Highway Patrol a notorious unit in
Philadelphia and they chased me about
nine blocks and I got caught by other
police officers who held me so they
walked up and this one officer hit me in
the mouth with a beaver tail Blackjack
and he split my mouth
for 86 stitches
that was December 4th 1981. I went home
and I hid in my bedroom
I kept sipping beer because the beer was
helping the cauterize the sutures
that were falling apart and my blood my
mouth kept bleeding for about two weeks
I was so despondent that I had lost
control again
but I couldn't stop wanting to get high
so on December 19th
I went out and another stolen car and
got high with my friend and dropped him
off and I was driving in the city of
Chester Pennsylvania when I got stopped
by officer Dan uh Benjamin Wright
it's two o'clock in the morning
I'm high as [__]
but I can't respond
I am so terrified of getting another
beating I didn't get out and run this
time I sat Frozen in the car gripping
the wheel while my brain is shutting
down from Aphasia and I can't see out of
my left eye he's walking up to the car
the music in this 1973 orange Camaro is
blasting it was
um bad companies
um song
silver blue and gold had just finished
and now Wildfire woman is blaring I
don't know
I'm so out of it I can't hear anything I
can't see anything I'm shut down next
thing I know he rips the door open and
grabs me by the shirt front and rips me
out of the car and starts yelling at me
but it's all gibberish then he put his
forearm against my for my throat and
pushed my head back against the roof of
the car and I'm choking and in one Fell
Swoop smash knocked his arm away from me
he reaches into his belt and takes the
night stick out but I'm on it and I take
the stick out of his hand and went like
that I was like what the [__] are you
doing like I'm I remember just yelling
them why and then he went for me and
then he stopped and he went down like
this with a gun and I was like whoa and
I reached out and I put both hands on
his wrist
and I swear to God all I wanted was to
just stop everything
but the gun went off
now we're stuck
in that moment as soon as the gun went
off and I felt it percussed all around
my body
I let go and I just started yelling okay
okay okay he put the pistol under my
mouth put me into the back seat of the
car a while yelling you stupid son of a
[__] you could have got us both killed
slams the door
he gets in the front seat he closes the
door we're sitting on top of the I-95
overpass
there's cars going underneath and he's
in the car and he looks at me in the
mirror
and he's Furious man like he was when he
ripped the door open
he grabs the microphone and I'm waiting
for him to tell what happened
and he goes into actor mode shots fired
shots fired officer assists I'm under
attack help help and then he drops the
mic
I'm like what the [__] what's this guy
doing
got out of the car and he paced back and
forth a Paddy Wagon came with officers
in another car
I hear him outside the car this
[__] tried to kill me I got my
gun back off him I should have shot him
in his head and all this I'm like oh no
like this ain't what happened like
I'm 20 years old man I'm a junkie from
Philly I just got caught in another
stolen car
nobody's going to believe [__] I got to
say
they open the back seat of the door Up
drag them out of the cop car beat the
[__] out of me put in the wagon took me
down
and they put in the county jail in
Chester
there was a African-American Sergeant on
duty name red a big mountain of a man
he told them they were not going to hang
me like right in front of them oh no you
ain't hanging this boy
I don't care what you said he'd done
y'all don't got him good they beat my
ass real good
he said but you wait
you let him go before the court you get
his photographs you don't do nothing you
don't touch this boy
Benny right was the son of the former
mayor so he was well connected
I stood next to skip to Mario public
defender at 3 45 A.M
according to my paperwork
and was read the following charges of
attempted murder kidnapping of a police
officer aggravated assault possession of
a firearm by a convicted felon
um and uh reckless endangerment
I was told that I was going to be held
with one hundred thousand dollars bail
and placed into the Broad Meadows prison
and the high security unit
and that I would be facing life
imprisonment if I was convicted of these
charges
it was three days before Christmas man I
lost it
I went to Broad Meadows prison and the
euphemism that they had back then was
drug treatment was three days of
intensive cell therapy
they put you in a cell and they lock the
door and they let you detox
and I crashed and I crashed hard
in my cell the only thing I had was that
December 15th Delaware County newspaper
with the front page missing and on page
three
the headline that kept bugging the hell
out of me for some reason because I
couldn't avoid reading it over and over
like we do when we're stuck in a toilet
we'll read the sign over and over
missing woman
police have mystery I'm looking at this
case for some reason I don't know why
I'm sitting there facing life
imprisonment from a lie and in my head I
stupidly concoct this idea
well if the game is all based on Who
Lies the best I'ma make up a lion get
out of this I'm gonna concoct a story
and say somebody did this crime like in
this newspaper and then when I get out
I'm out of here I'm running
this is the stupid mentality of a 20
year old drug addict
so
a year before all of this happens
I was abducted by a couple of guys in
Philadelphia beaten with my own pistol
rolled up in a rug and driven around in
a pickup truck until they decided to
dump me behind the old Westinghouse
Warehouse down by the Delaware River
oh
I had heard that the man who
orchestrated the attack Jimmy had died
of a drug overdose but it wasn't it was
his brother Joseph
the guy telling me the story was telling
me as a Grace to have me not obsessively
keep hunting for this guy Thinking by
telling me Jimmy's dead I'd give up
because that's all I talked about
I went to the police and I told them
that Jimmy had committed the murder and
confessed it to me after he was out
stealing cars
the police initially believed me they
took me out of solitary confinement and
they told me that they'd spoken to
officer Wright who was willing to drop
my charges down to resisting arrest and
I would be prosecuted for the stolen car
in Philadelphia if all of this was true
that I was telling them to help solve
this enormous case
I went from sitting in solitary
confinement on D Block in broadmeadows
prison to be taken to the warden's
office and told I had a deal on the
table I could be released in three days
all they had to do was verify what I
said
I was like so close to believing this
myself
three days later the police came back to
me and there was no Smiles no free soft
drinks no accolades about me doing good
community service
they wanted to know why
and when I told him I lied because of
what our officer Wright lied about they
said no no no no no no no
we don't want to hear that [__]
officer writes pressing charges to the
fullest amount you're going to be put
away for life
and
we're going to strap you into the
electric chair for killing that woman
because we know you did it and you came
to us to tell us it but you just didn't
have the courage
we know you have a troubled childhood
and you've been in and out of the
juvenile system for years we know it was
you
I couldn't believe this
[Music]
I couldn't believe in an instant
the detectives
had formulated this idea that it had to
have been me
I had made this one detective Randy
Martin so angry that when they took me
out and interrogated me for 13 hours
and I refused to tell them anything
other than I was sorry I lied
I was messed up
they brought me back to the Delaware
County Prison
and he gave me a hug in front of the
Pagan motorcycle prisoners who were in
the process unit and told me thanks for
that information Nick we're going to go
kick some doors in boy and I was stunned
I was like what what do you they set me
up
I go back to b d block in Broad Motors
prison and the next morning I get bleach
and urine thrown in my face a guy tries
to put my eye out with a sharpened broom
and there's four Dudes outside my cell
trying to kill me
call me a rat
saying that they saw me with the CID and
that they know it's me
I can't believe that they did this
Sinister thing where the police set me
up to be pressurized inside the prison
knowing I have a mental disorder knowing
that I'm weak and vulnerable and for a
week I got abused every time I came out
myself I fought just one thing
I was getting in the shower
see dudes was going buying gas in me man
throwing milk cartons of urine and feces
at my cell I had to put my mattress up
against the door and block it for as
long as I could stand up and then when
they kicked my door whoever was outside
I was [__] them up
I don't care if you did anything to me
or not I was getting somebody
because I had to send a message to these
guys
and I go in the shower and wash off and
go back to my stinking cell and lock the
door I did that for a week and then I
hung myself the guard caught me
hanging from the radiator cut me down
and said no no no no no you're not
cheating the state of Pennsylvania
we don't allow that
they took me to the hospital and
strapped me down on all fours and let my
mom visit me and while I was getting a
visit from my mom guys were going by
getting her medication and they were
touching themselves and saying all kind
of lewd things about me and my mother
my mother at that time said to me Nikki
I don't know
what you're doing
but I do know this I need you
to never hurt yourself
you you're my gift
to life
everything that you are is a gift
so I swore her I wouldn't kill myself
after that
they went back to the block
and they put a guy in a Cell next to me
from one night named Charles catalino
Charles was convicted of burglarizing
the prosecutor's home of Delaware County
where we were at
he was convicted of a jury and he was
facing 20 years in prison for this
conviction
one night he was in a Cell next to me
then they moved me out of the jail and
put me in Chester County Prison and I
was charged with the rape and murder of
Mrs Craig a woman I never met I only
read about a newspaper
Charles said that I confess to him of
the rape and murder
so that I was worried about my blood
being found on the on the scene
and um
that I I did it all because I was
despondent over me and my girlfriend
Terry breaking up
the police used this as the onus to
charge me no weapon no murder weapon no
Witnesses
a jailhouse confession
another lie
I was given a trial for the Benny Wright
charges for the attempted murder and I
was acquitted by the jury after only 20
minutes of deliberation why it was
simple
Benny Wright just made up a story and he
had this notion that by getting at me in
court
by expounding upon and lying further
he could get at me in the courtroom
he saw me get upset when he first
started telling the lion he got so much
schadenfreude enjoyment from it he kept
lying
he told the jury that when he pulled me
over I jumped out of the car before he
had a chance to look up from his log
book
and rip him out of the car punched him
in his face broke his eyeglasses then I
took the gun out of his holster and beat
him with it and I was holding the gun up
ready to blow his brains out when he
heroically reached up and took the gun
off me and subdued me
that's the story Benny Wright told the
jury
my lawyer only asked him a few questions
and one of them was
you took a photograph of your hand
showing where you were cut where Mr
Yaris took the gun off of you
then he hit you in the face with it
after punching you and breaking your
eyeglasses
you were so astute to take that
photograph of your hand
why didn't you photograph your face
where you did all the damage with a
pistol
and he froze
officer Wright knew right then and there
at that moment The Jig was up because
how do you answer that and he had no
answers so he said look I'm a good
looking man I don't have to answer that
I didn't want to see I didn't want
people to see me with bruises on my face
okay
but Jerry's like nah you went out of
your way to make a photograph of that
man taking a gun off you by a scratch
but you didn't want nobody to see where
he hit you you would have wanted us to
see that so that's why they acquitted me
of all the charges of attempted murder
and everything
the case was being prosecuted by a man
by the name of Barry gross assistant
prosecutor he went berserk in the
courtroom
he took the case File and threw it
against the wall
he turned right as I was leaving and he
said [__] you'll never leave
this County alive
Barry gross had nothing to do with the
homicide prosecution it was being
handled by someone else at that time but
after the acquittal by the jury he took
over the murder prosecution that I was
charged with of Linda May Craig and then
for the first time ever began seeking
the death penalty
the judge took over the trial as well
Robert F Kelly wasn't even supposed to
be my trial judge but he took that over
too so
he privately told
my lawyer he blamed himself for my
acquittal because they didn't mention I
was in a stolen car as if that had
anything to do with this man lying on
the stand
they were going to put me up against the
death penalty because they knew when you
select a death-prone jury you're 90
percent more likely to get any kind of
conviction instead of missing out again
at the age of 21 I was given a three-day
murder trial in Delaware County
I knew it was a three-day murder trial
because his honor opened and remarks to
the jury and told them listen
I know you all have a Monumental worry
before you
that this weekend is the Fourth of July
holiday weekend
but I got good news for you all I'm
gonna have this trial over and you will
be home to celebrate with your family
this week and I'm not going to sequester
you
it was Tuesday when he told him that
they were trying to get out of there by
Friday
the trial really hinged only on he said
she said words
but one factor
there was photographs taken Where Mrs
Craig was found in the snow after she
was abducted in the state of Delaware
where she had been kidnapped
driven into Pennsylvania where she was
sexually assaulted and then stabbed and
dumped in the snow where she was
discovered by two young boys the next
day
the photograph was black and white
[Music]
and the horror of it was
you could see the children's footprints
right next to where the body was were
deep red
eventually fading out
and in Terror they ran in different ways
so for all the world it looked like an
angel
laying in the snow from above where they
photographed it
they showed that photograph after
showing Mrs Craig on the autopsy table
and they got away with it all by saying
that since the photographs were black
and white that would not excite the
passions of the jury to show them the
disfigurement of a woman laying there
with six visible stab wounds
all I knew was that the jury couldn't
look at me after they looked at those
photographs
prior to that they did
in fact everyone stopped being able to
look me in the eye
I kept challenging people I was so
indignant I'm like what are you doing I
didn't kill anyone
but when you're 21 years old no one has
any time for you
the jury
took the time to go to the Wagon Wheel
restaurant
after convicting me of murder and rape
to have dinner
they were making sure they was getting
us over
the Eerie thing was there was a huge
storm that came through the Delaware
Valley and a boat of lightning
hit the courthouse and knocked the power
out
it was like my Marley moment
I couldn't believe that I was being
escorted through these clig lights up to
a holding cell and I was watching people
out in the courtyards of the building
that had been emptied after the court
been struck by the lightning
they looked up and they saw me
some of them waved some jeered
I knew some
I waited
I knew that the jury had gone off to eat
they asked me if I wanted something
myself and I said no
they said Well when the jury comes back
they'll have
gotten things done
and the sheriff said I can't believe it
and he kept saying this to me I can't
believe and I said to him what do you
mean sir that they found me good he goes
no
when they were over there
deliberating for you to be convicted
they were having dinner
and some of them had the nerve to ask
the waiters to hold on to their desserts
so that after they came back and read my
verdict they could go back and
deliberate whether or not to put me to
death while they had to deserve
I don't know
I went back in the courtroom and I
waited for someone to look in my eye
and the judge when he sentenced me to
death
couldn't look me in the eye
he said to me are you finished when I
told him look you know it's obvious I
didn't kill anyone I was home with my
mother my father and my sister having
dinner
28 miles away from the murder scene
there's no possible way with a bank
receipt at 3 pm that day that this
murder happens at 405 that I I'm
anywhere near Delaware killing this
woman
but he couldn't look me in the face
and he said do you have anything else to
say I said yeah you can go to hell look
at me you can't even look me in your eye
and you're about to sentence me to die
and you can't look me in the eye you can
go to hell
that's all the newspaper group
defiant murderer tells judge go to hell
oh man when they got me into State
Penitentiary oh
I was the second youngest person ever
sentenced to die in Pennsylvania there
was only 27 of us
and
I made the mistake of getting into an
altercation with a correctional officer
who was teaching me about Christianity
by strip searching me with his fellow
officer sticking his fingers in my anus
and then rubbing them on my face and
telling me about Jesus
so I punched them
hard as I [__] could to
and it was worth the beating and getting
locked up but they blamed that as one of
the reasons they locked down
Pennsylvania's death row so I had no
friends on death row they sent me to
Huntington prison
Huntington State Prison
in the early 80s was the only prison
ever condemned by the United Nations for
its active practices of torture
if you spoke in your cell and you broke
the silence rule four Burly guards in
riot gear rush into your cell with a
nurse who's wearing a helmet and a black
vest
she's got a needle in her hand full of
Thorazine 1 000 milligrams she rushes in
when they got you down and Jabs you in
the ass and says it's done
and you're left like a drooling monster
you just oh my God so for a week of your
life you can't even talk because you're
so high off of Thorazine it takes
forever for that drug to get out of your
system
now if that didn't work they upped the
next level
so they had a
a cell built out of glass bricks
the object was keep the light on 24
hours a day put you in that cell because
they got tired of hitting you with the
Thorazine
and make you do a head count every 15
minutes for a week
that means you have to get up stand at
attention and be counted every 15
minutes
after about a week of that you go into
white out
white out is when you no longer have
consciousness of your surroundings and
this is what they were doing to
prisoners at Huntington when I got there
they took everybody else off the bus
they lined me up against the wall and
the lieutenant explained the rules to me
that I wasn't allowed to speak of myself
and when I stupidly broke the rules by
saying yes sir
he backhanded me
he went on to tell me that I was dead
and that everybody I knew or loved was
dead and dead men didn't speak in his
unit
snapped his fingers and said 30 seconds
and that's when they pounced they beat
me for 30 seconds with clubs hold your
breath for 30 seconds that's a challenge
hold on to your sanity while men are
ripping it into your legs with Riot
sticks professionally whacking you
all right
throw me in a cell and the nurse comes
up and by wrote starts reading off the
process unit intake paperwork that I
need to use to see a doctor
a dc-138
-8 medical form would be provided to me
if I needed to see a doctor I'm standing
there willing this lady to look at me
just look at my face lady look at the
blood look at what they just did to me
she had her head down she would not look
up so I refused to answer her hoping to
get her to look at me and she knew the
routine
the guard would wait and say inmate
makes no response and she'd read off the
next thing and make makes no response
then I was finally at the end of that
handed a form of where to put my where
to send my body or
put my body when I was done after they
executed me
I'm 21 years old I'm thinking how the
hell can I live where I can't talk
and
it's all a joke
so I used to sit in my cell and beat my
head against the wall
I thought at first
if I stayed on it if I stayed Street
angry ain't no [__] gonna break
me like that
stupid mentality
I remember they'd have to patch my head
up
take me to the triage
for all the times I beat my head open
and I was taken there by a guard an OG
guard been there for a long time and he
kind of took pity on me
we were coming back past a cell that was
empty from a man that killed himself by
jumping off the top tier
and he said boy go in that cell get some
of them books that'll stop you from
being angry
so I walked in hurriedly grabbed five
books that weren't urine stained or
ruined and I ended up with an amazing
treasure
and I went back to my soul
and I began working as best as I could
on my own
because of one thing
I was tired of being humiliated by not
being able to process language and
having people speak over to my
intelligence level
words flew past my ears at my own trial
and it was devastating to have your life
decided when you were
guttural you spoke an ugly form
it took me a long time to start off and
I had so many headaches
having aphasia
I also discovered that I have a a weird
form
of Dyslexia where I can't visualize
numbers
how the hell am I going to deal with
this like if
I know it's described to me you know six
with the three or you know six times
three people can do the calculation in
their head they can see it you know it's
18 right
when I had to take middle blue and
second red
put them together and times them because
I had to contrive
an ability in my brain to do math
by coming up with number systems at one
three five
seven and nine are all various types of
red
and two four six and eight are various
types of blue
with the zero being black I can come up
with math in my brain so I knew I wasn't
stupid I I knew I was kind of bright
I also had the devastating
thing of being assigned public defenders
to defend me on appeal
who didn't believe in me
my first attorney told me he was an
ex-military officer and he supported the
death penalty but he was filing my
appeal
perfunctory
he didn't care about me and he didn't
want me to waste his time trying to tell
him I was guilty I mean not guilty
because he had gone through the records
and he thought it was a solid conviction
the best he had hoped for is just to get
me a life sentence so I could live out
my remaining years in prison and not
rape and kill anybody else he said
[Music]
I couldn't believe that I had waited
through two years of Silence to meet my
first lawyer and he tells me all this
crap
I knew I had to become clever I had to
educate myself because
Not only was the system willing to
squash me like a bug and play with me
but anybody they gave me for help was
going to be a joke
I started
I tried
and then
the appeal was filed and I'm being taken
to court in 1985
I can't believe that this guy filed the
appeal the state supreme court said he
was right that I should have never been
convicted of rape I mean kidnapping rape
and robbery altogether as the underlying
aggravating crimes that led to me being
sentenced to death because those crimes
happened in the state of Delaware
she was abducted in the state of
Delaware I could not be convicted of
kidnapping in Pennsylvania
I was going to get off of that floor at
least at a minimum
I'm going to be given an evidentiary
hearing on all 33 pages of the homicide
file that disappeared when I became the
prime suspect and all of the material
related to the actual suspect is gone
I'm so eager to get the court I can't
believe it in February of 1985
I'm being transported from Death Row to
court
and we stopped to go to the toilet
and in a series of Hazard
crazy
unpredictable circumstances
I escaped from death row and I end up on
the FBI's most wanted list for the next
25 days
this is crazy
I'm going to take a piss at a gas
station in Sub-Zero temperatures the
coldest night of the year I'm wearing
prison shoes prison trousers a prison
shirt
I ain't thinking about anything but
going into the cubicle and urinating and
getting my ass back in the car
while I was taking a piss
the officer who went over with me
stood and held the top of the door open
so he could watch me
but standing there his bladder gave away
and he had to go so bad he made a
decision to let me just go back to the
car by myself
he was too far away to say anything to
his partner
I came out I went under his arm I ducked
down
I went back to the car and I'm doing
that weird thing because my hands are
cuffed
and he's not behind me but I don't know
it the officer in front of me who was
smoking a cigarette looked up and saw me
trotting at him in the dark doesn't see
his partner and freaks and he pulls the
gun like that and when he went with the
gun pulling out I said what are you
doing and
bam like no warning no halt none of that
television bam the first shot went off
and I turned and I ran
oh my God
I ran but my arms are cuffed I can't get
the normal Locomotion that we do when we
run and I'm going downhill and I fell
when he fired the second shot I went
down and I lost all the skin off my
hands and it was so painful it jolted me
awake like wait a minute man this is it
go
I ran
just like a street kid a hundred yards
to the right there was a gas station no
cars available I ran another 100 yards
to the right I ran another 100 yards to
the right and I ended up right behind
the cop car that I just got out of and
escaped and I watched them shouting at
each other and going back and forth
while I was laying in the grass no more
than 40 yards from them
I took off my prison eyeglasses I was
hyperventilating I started vomiting I
couldn't stop vomiting from the shock
and then I got myself together I took
the end off of my eyeglasses and I took
the handcuffs off
having worn a handcuffs for years I
learned how to get out of them
I took my cuffs off I put them in my
pocket
and I looked up and there was a flag on
a building and I I knew it was a
municipal building and it was a
police station so I actually went and
navigated around the gas station in the
woods and the weeds and I crawled behind
the police station I hid there but it
was so cold that where I was hiding was
water that was frozen and I was hiding
down in this recessed area by the
building
and I just kept getting the body shakes
and freezing and freezing I couldn't
take it anymore
when I was convulsing from the cold so
badly that it was breaking my ribs
almost I jumped up and I took off to the
parking lot and someone in the building
saw me and they called in the helicopter
and for the next five hours I was chased
by this very dedicated pilot
at one point
I was running
and
it was the end of a parking lot there
was so much snow
that when the plows had been pushing the
snow they made a gap in the fence
I didn't know this I was running
full on as fast as I could with the
helicopter blades down on me down on me
like that as soon as I hit the back end
I slid for like 20 yards and I saw the
fence come on at me and I put my arms up
and I dropped because it had been so
much of a gap I didn't even hit the
fence and I slid down and I ended up
jumping up and running to the right and
hiding under this tractor trailer and he
kept circling and circling and he
couldn't find me and I made it out of
there and I went across this parking lot
and I found some railroad tracks
and I walked on broken feet with both
hamstrings strings pulled
and I couldn't believe it I made it five
miles to Fraser Pennsylvania
where in the parking lot there was a
1965 green Fastback Mustang I hot-wired
the car
I drove to Darby Pennsylvania
and I got a coin out of the car seat and
I called a family member and I asked
them for help
I got some money off of them some
bandages and a hat from the Philadelphia
Eagles football team
and I drove to New York City in that car
right away leaving the area
I went up to New York
and at the time you could get a flop
House hotel room for fourteen dollars in
the Bowery
I got a room
I got a loaf of bread some lunch meat
and a box of Epsom salt and I sat in
that room for days picking institutional
clothing out of my ripped up flesh
my face and everything was just torn up
so bad from just running blind Terror
through the woods
[Music]
a couple days later I came out of my
hotel and I was walking on Madison
and I saw all the Macy's display windows
with televisions and I saw the news
reports of me on some of the channels
and I started freaking out and I was
wondering if everybody was like able to
just look at me and say hey that's you
but nobody even was looking you know
so I I went down to the West Village and
I was walking around and I saw this two
men in the window
of a uh hair salon
and they were talking amicably and
nicely
and in an instant it just came to me
I burst into the door and I was like
please please can you help me can you
help me he keeps beating me look what
he's done to me and they were like oh oh
my God who's doing it I said my
boyfriend look what he's done to me they
sat me in the chair
they they permed my hair dyed it black
taught me how to put makeup on in two
and a half hours after I did that stunt
I walked out of there without paying him
a penny and I looked completely
different
I was gone
I had black curly hair
different eyeglasses for fifty dollars
from a shop they recommended me to
I couldn't believe it
I went to Laguardia Airport after I
stole a guy's coat that had his wallet
in it and I got on an airplane with no
photographic identification anything
needed back then
and I flew to Orlando Florida and I went
looking for a pawn shop so I could sell
this fur coat that I stole in New York
City out of a a restaurant and I'm
thinking get out of America man just go
I don't know
it was too hard
like I I was I was complexly blown away
at one point I met this girl and I hung
out with her at her mom's a little like
business
and we had amazing time together and she
invites me to her house the next day and
I I say yeah but when I get there it's
dinner like I thought go get you know
pick her up I ended up while on Escape
being a dinner guest for a family who
later on when they found out who I was
her mom said I was still the most polite
boy she had ever brought home man it was
that kind of crazy I can't explain it
but like I was trying not to get caught
up in being normalized I was trying to
also not think about any minute they're
going to catch me they're going to blow
my brains out and all this you know
oh
I'm sitting on the one in Florida and
there's a Navy Army Navy Store
and it's got the big rubber yellow raft
in the window
and I had a plan
I was going to go in that store
and I was going to buy that raft
and then I was going to get all my
favorite treats and I was going to
paddle out into the shipping lanes
I was going to have one amazing meal
watching the sunset in Florida
then I was going to cut my wrist wait
for the Sharks to show up I was going to
blow my brains out because I didn't want
my family to see me in handcuffs ever
again
then part of me said man
then you're always going to beat it in
history that murderer that's all you'll
ever be man
from coward that ran
so I turned myself back in they couldn't
believe it
the Volusia County Jail had me under the
charges of a stolen car and I had to
bail money I was ready to leave I got
tired of I couldn't do this no more
I called my dad I said poppy do me a
favor
I need you to call the FBI and tell them
I'm in the Volusia County Jail I'm under
the name Daniel Joseph Corbett I'm being
held for 500 I've got fifteen hundred
dollars on me I can get out of here
right now
I want to come home I want to fight this
thing
he said you sure
I said yeah he said all right hang up
next thing I knew all the guards in the
prison ran to get me man strip me naked
chained me up and walked me through the
female wing of the prison to get to the
high security unit
I was holding my junk rattling and
rolling man it was crazy
so I get put on Florida's death row
and end up next to coward asked Ted
Bundy for eight months in the heat
there's no matches in Stark Florida
prison
they were blowing each other's heads off
with handmade shotguns by taking sulfur
and Flint from the striker of books of
matches until you had enough to make
powder and then getting Pebbles and
glass and taking a metal pipe and
crimping off one end melting a spoon
around the hole that you've managed to
dig into the pipe so sticking an
electrical cord into that hole and
wrapping the other one around the
exterior of that pipe and then when
someone walks past your cell you plug
the cord into the wall
and the electricity ignites the charge
and you blow someone's head off
I was on top of Q wing three stories
above Yellow Mama the electric chair
and I had to
The Misfortune of sitting there
listening
through the vents to [__] Bundy cry
about anything he could [__] about
while no one had any time for him
because he had made it known that he had
sex on a visit they took all the dudes
visits off of death row so everybody
on the wing wanted to kill his little
[__] ass
I went back to Pennsylvania I ruined my
appeals everything was screwed up bad
there was no such thing as death row
Florida added 35 years to my sentences
so
in 1987 I was sitting in Pennsylvania's
death row with 105 years of sentences
plus the death penalty
and I had no hope that was it I was done
so the strangest thing happens is this
whole case began with a newspaper left
in a cell that I was initially arrested
in and
a convicted serial rapist by the name of
Dennis Sheffield is throwing away a
newspaper
and he asked me if I wanted it and I had
the guard pass it to me and it was the
Philadelphia Inquirer and on the front
section of the
Science and Technology was a photograph
of Sir Alec Jeffries and his invention
of DNA science and how courts in Florida
had just convicted a man by proving it
was his DNA
based on the work of Sir Alec Jeffries
back in England solving the Colin
Pitchfork murder case in leicestershire
by gathering all the blood samples of
men between a certain age in the village
and showing it was Colin that did the
murder
I was like oh my God are you kidding me
they gotta now this is the craziest
thing I was partially convicted because
whoever killed and then raped Mrs Craig
had B positive blood
I have B positive blood and I'm a
secreter of that antigen but in the 19
early 80s that didn't really do you know
Define it DNA changed everything I was
shaken with joy I was so sure I could
prove my innocence I was the very first
prisoner
in America to seek DNA testing from
Death Row in 1988.
no other prisoner on death row at that
time had ever sought DNA testing no
other convicted prisoner at that time
had filed anything in February 88
I had the honor and horrible distinction
of being the first man to try and prove
his innocence with DNA
I didn't know right at that moment it
was going to take me 15 agonizing years
from that moment for DNA to be relevant
in my life
I only knew that they were going to
orchestrate an effort to Murder Me by
destroying evidence
my first lawyer Joe Bullard told me to
that the the coroner was so eager to see
that this would be done his office would
be part of the first case in America
and that I should call him back on a
Monday morning so that they could they
could discuss which laboratory the
evidence would be shipped to because he
just got off the phone remember with the
coroner who said they had all of the
autopsy material from the Linda May
Craig homicide available for DNA testing
I got on the phone Monday
and it was a different Joe
he said I spoke to the corner just 15
minutes ago ignoring what I'm saying
about this or that
and the coroners found out that all of
the evidence has been destroyed sorry Mr
Harris
they don't know what happened to it
they've gone through all their files
I said how can I be on death row if
there's no evidence to prove me guilty
then because it doesn't work that way
they had the evidence to convict you
they don't need to keep it I said this
doesn't make a decision
so I was starting to yell I wanted to
get upset but
I'm in a unit where
if I raised my voice the guard standing
behind me are just going to lash into my
thighs with those like those sticks
I let it go man I
hung the phone up I went back to my cell
you know I was
so angry that all the evidence was gone
and I kept saying be positive
who got me here right
be positive
well
I picked up my trial notes and I started
reading them
and in what's called sidebar where the
defendants never present
conversations were had prior to
Witnesses and this one little footnote
Dr Muhammad Tahir
National Medical Services
Willow Grove Pennsylvania
before he testified
about the B positive blood groups
because they were asked to do the
serological work
he said he had numerous well-preserved
slides at his lab
and I went oh
I wonder if he still has them
so I wrote him a personal letter
and I said dear doctor to hear I'm
convicted of the Linda May Craig a
homicide I hope you remember me but I
was wondering did you keep the evidence
from that case
he wrote me back and said yeah I have it
I was like wow he wrote me back on death
row and said I do indeed have well
preserved slides that have numerous
well-preserved spermatozoa visible to
the eye
on them
two detectives from the prosecutor's
office went there without a court order
and took that evidence and put that in
her desk for the next three years
when I finally got it back
I couldn't believe in 1992 I got the
federal court to finally listen to me
and when the evidence came from Delaware
County District Attorney's Office of the
CID
there was nothing left on those slides
a detective named David Pfeiffer
tried to murder me I knew right then it
was going to be hard I knew I had no
chance but I had to become seriously
strong
at that time I had just met a woman
named Jackie
I was so humiliated by being on death
row by my own
stupid making up of a story
I was more embarrassed by that and I
would rather have her think I was guilty
that I didn't tell her I was innocent
for six months
imagine having feelings for someone
and caring about them and they come and
visit you and yet you don't have the
courage to tell them you're innocent
a because it would have been a huge
emotional burden on them to know I was
suffering all this for no reason and B
you put yourself there by making up a
stupid story
huh
I only told her because of the DNA
and I thought
this would work you know
we contacted the Sally Jesse Raphael
Show we tried to do the show together I
kept contacting
journalists and all of these
organizations
all these innocence projects and
everyone turned me down
it went on for years
and Jackie
came to visit me
after nine years
when I finally got the federal court to
investigate and find the victim's
clothes my mother recalled at the end of
the trial they tried to give her the
victim's clothes so we had a hearing and
my mom was the hero of the day and found
the evidence
the evidence was being shipped to
California so Dr Blake could test the
evidence
and it burst open in shipping and he
refused to do the testing
so all the evidence was officially
deemed
distorted or destroyed
and Jackie God bless her
came to see me I was up in Pittsburgh
Penitentiary I was actually in the cell
right next to the original Buffalo Bill
Gary heidnick A Man Who Loved to abduct
women and put them in the basement of
his house and torture them
I was surrounded by all these Mad Men
like Gary and Jackie walks in and tells
me
you can't take it no more
her mom was dying of emphysema she's got
a house full of legal book boxes of my
work
and this ain't going nowhere and all the
evidence is gone
and she met someone named Bob and she
thought she wanted to be happy
and she had to go
I was 39 years old
I had just spent 18 years on death row
nine of which I was deeply in love with
this woman
so
I went on a mad journey of finishing my
education
and meanwhile I circumnavigated the
planet by sending Snippets of my hair to
pen pals all over the world thinking I
would never
see the ocean again
and when I found out about DNA I thought
[__] it
if I Gotta Die in here
I'm gonna get some friends of mine to
send my DNA all over the world
but but I wasn't done with this journey
and
I started getting sick
at one point in prison six two 240
pounds I was working out on this amazing
kundaliga yoga program taking care of
myself
I was doing good man I had a hustle I
got two guys off a death row by doing
their legal work for him
I was well respected people who actually
knew who I was and trusted who I was
but I was I was diagnosed with Hepatitis
C after a couple others on the unit died
of it
foreign
when I came back from Escape in 1987 in
Pennsylvania they beat me
for four minutes and they broke my teeth
and
the dentist
didn't change the suction return sleeves
and he infected
12 or 15 of us with this very viral
strain of Hepatitis C
so
the euphemism name that we had for him
was Doctor death because so many guys
died in the dentist chair but here was a
new level
he gave us all hepatitis C
now
I listened in Greene County prison in
as Dale Carter convicted of rape and
murder like me
died in his cell
[Music]
the nurses would come to his soul
and facetiously mock him Mr Carter
would you like an aspirin would you like
something for your pain
and he would scream out [__] you know
I'm dying I need some morphine
help me please don't let me suffer like
this well you should have thought about
that when you killed that woman Mr Miss
Carter
I bet you she suffered too
and he'd walk on
and I'm thinking no man don't let them
do this to you Nikki
you fought too hard to be somebody that
you can respect and love don't
[__] let them do that to you
watching Carter die
gave me an idea
you see the very first man in
Pennsylvania's history in the modern era
to be put to death was Keith zettelmeyer
an absolute passive soul of a man they
broke his hip up in Huntington prison
where he did time with me up there by
throwing him down a flight of metal
steps
Keith killed his Beth's friend
they were doing burglaries together they
got caught his friend told on a turn
States evident
Keith took his friend down to the river
and shot him in the head
other than that Keith wasn't no criminal
he was a nice guy he was so sorry for
what he did I never seen a man pray and
worship God and
seek forgiveness but he couldn't take it
no more so he asked to be executed and I
watched him be walked to his death just
like I watched the real Buffalo Bill
Gary heidnick
seeking Glory do the same thing
I was going to use that example to take
control of this I was not going to go
out with the nurses and others standing
at my door mocking me
so I wrote a letter to the federal court
and I asked to be executed after sitting
in my cell
blind for three solid days because
this is how the medications are
distributed in Pennsylvania prisons at
the time
they have inmate workers
who sometimes are in charge of the
scripts
so I was being given three
horse pills
of interferon
and being jabbed would interfere on
these cancer-fighting jobs uh injections
three times a week
so nine pills a day I was supposed to be
taken turned into 12 pills a day because
I was given the medication too much
it toxified my system shut my kidneys
down and blinded
I was so
distraught
that it happened out in the exercise
yard and they beat me
I'm like this is insane so if I get sick
and I'm in the yard it's a move on you
oh my God leave me alone with this
because it's getting too much
so I sat down in December of 2002 and I
asked to be executed
the federal court knowing that I had
been a DNA
effort prisoner for 15 years
decided to have Dr Edward Blake do the
remaining tests
in February of 2003
the Killer's gloves that were left in
the automobile that were never tested
that were hidden from my defense council
at my trial yielded DNA from an unknown
male number one
they also revealed DNA from a second
possible female victim
now at that time I heard he dismissed my
appeals and asked to be executed I was
brought to a hearing and my fidgeting
hands lawyers were telling me look we
have one shot left these are consumptive
tests if you want these tests done on
the victim's underwear and other items
that Dr Blake has in his possession you
have to agree that if they are not proof
positive of your innocence that that's
it
I said go I don't have time to argue go
like I didn't fight this fight this long
and then there's a question and I'm like
oh well I better stop go
July of 2003
um I was sitting in Graterford prison
having been brought to the Philadelphia
area for court when the phone was
brought to my cell
it was like Garris got a phone call so I
was hoping it was my mom or something
you know so pick up the phone get on it
wait through the mechanical process to
click through and it's Michael Wiseman
of the federal defender's office and
he's like Nick just got the paperwork
faxed to us from Dr Blake I was sitting
there reading it I want you to go
through it with his um so the DNA that
was found in the Killer's glove of
unknown male number one
matches DNA from spermatozoa of
which was found in Mrs Craig's underwear
and he starts slowing down I'm screaming
oh my God oh my God don't you see it
proves me innocent his sperm and the DNA
from his gloves that was left at the
crime scene and he's like oh my God
it actually yeah this proves you're
innocent he goes oh Nick I gotta tell
you man you don't know how many times we
were sitting around saying what if he's
actually and I'm like no I don't have
time for your [__] reminiscent about
how you as counsel thought I was insane
and you held on and did this for me
gratis
um so I hung the phone up for him and I
clicked it back and I got some time left
I called my mom
I was like Mom listen
they got the DNA back from Dr Blake and
I'm innocent she goes oh thank God I
knew it was going to come out but Nikki
I can't take this call right now Mikey's
laying at my feet he's having a grand
mal seizure he's off his medication he's
been drinking again I gotta go
talk about the worst possible scenario
it broke me it did
the guard came back to get the phone and
he found me laying on my bed huddled
crying incredibly because I'm innocent
all the guards on the unit were in on
why I was there
the inmates next to me are shouting get
the [__] out Nick get out and do
something with your life
he took me down the hall and he put me
in the shower and he put a plastic chair
in there because I was so shaky
he said just go in there it's too hot
it's July get under there
and he smacked the button and left me
under the shower
and I started
I cried because
my little brother Marty died the year
before the drug overdose in my parents
basement
my father got fired from over so many
jobs or mistreated my
parents would tell me how people would
bring them up in the middle of night
tell them what scumbags they were for
being my parents
right
and I knew
this wasn't somehow
it wasn't over man
you don't beat me like this and beat me
like this and then you stop it's over
the administration came to me
they said Dear Mr Yaris like we're so
happy for you what's happening in the
news is wonderful but if till it becomes
official and they walk you out of the
prison
we're keeping you in level five Maximum
Security Prison cell because you're one
of the most dangerous prisoners we've
ever held and we're not going to trust
you
I said wait a minute whoa whoa whoa
you broke my hands you beat me you
you
beat me
I I haven't heard anyone
you made me fight other men but I didn't
choose to do that
like what's wrong with you they said
look
with your history and what we've done to
you
we don't believe that anybody could go
through what you've gone through
and not be angry
and as such we think that you you would
get revenge on one of us if given the
opportunity so until they open the door
and let you out you're going to sit in a
level five maximum security so
and we're taking everything off you
so you can't make no weapons
so over the last eight months they put
me in an empty cell with two towels
a sheet
pillowcases like that's it nothing a
plastic cart and milk carton a drink on
them
they thought by taking all of my
paintings or my books and everything
I don't know maybe they would force me
to just break mentally I don't know what
they were thinking
but it became this beautiful opportunity
for me to sit in my cell
and start drainage daydreaming about the
type of person I wanted to try and find
Within Myself
at the very beginning I told you I had
the utter distinction of having started
my life twice
the second time I began my life was
January 16th 2004
[Music]
I was 42 years old and I was standing in
front of a prison
and I had just gone through the horror
of having my release botched earlier
that morning
and I had to stay calm and speak for the
men who were innocent in the prison
behind me
I had to get in a car with my parents
and drive across Pennsylvania
in the front seat I watched them hold
their hands together
I knew
this was going to be the onset
of the hardest challenge of my life
somehow
I knew this was going to be bigger than
death row
at the age of 42
I stood in front of my parents house
on the evening of my release
and I spoke to the Press
then
I went inside with everyone
and I was
I hate to say this
I was allergic to hugging human beings
you see
if I held someone all of their energy
would impact me so much it would make me
shiver
and I was vibrating with so much life
that if I hugged or touched others they
were getting shocks
and that I couldn't explain it
I sat there and we waited around and the
10 o'clock news came on and then the 11
o'clock news
purposefully pushed myself back as far
as I could away from everyone in the
room
because
unlike them
I didn't know what I looked like
I didn't have a mirror in myself
I had a scratched up piece of metal on
my wall for so long
and I never saw photographs to myself or
anything
I wondered what I look like
so I sat back in the corner
and I waited
and I looked on screen
I didn't make the connection
who was this man
prison eyeglasses a baseball cap
standing there with these people
that's not me
I'm over here to Nikki
like that's not that's a that's
a fully grown man
it was so deep
I've been shot stabbed strangled run
over by an automobile
two drug overdoses I hung myself in a
prison cell I lived through 23 years of
solitary confinement that included two
prison riots
and I'm saying
the only thing I can derive from all of
that
is that
what a wonderful chance to be somebody
what a wonderful chance to have meaning
to people and show them that you don't
have to capitulate to your ego you don't
have to go seeking validity by blaming
others shit's gonna happen you're going
to get the shitty end of the stick
you're going to get beat down things are
going to go bad but you define who you
are in the aftermath of that
you define
what you deserved of it what you didn't
deserve of it and your actions
and more importantly
never let anyone steal your kindness
It Is What Makes You uniquely Who You
Are
I've gone through this enormous thing
of having two distinct starting points
in life
the first one I had no control over this
one I do
as such
I'm going to continue on trying to do
something to make meaningfulness
out of all of this
My Hope
is that I continue on using my efforts
as an author
to write things
and actions in life as well
so that my daughter
who haven't seen who's now 16 years old
soon to be 17 in April
will have a lasting lingering memory of
the good that I was
I don't have anything else left
I have been
tested
but not broken
otherwise
I am so grateful to be here
I feel like
this would be the last time I ever speak
in America
that's a great sense of accomplishment
that I have made here
and now I'm free to go on and seek
happiness again
I'm still in love I'm still alive I'm
still a good person
so I should have those dreams
just as all of you should have
I want to thank Mark
bringing me here to share all this with
all of you
I'm eternally grateful to know
before you heard my voice today
you felt alone but you now know
we share that same commonality and I
love you I love you for being the decent
person that helps others
I love you for being the thankless
person who doesn't do things to be
thanked but it's nice to have them
I want to take time at the conclusion
here to say
I believe so much in good
that I was willing to walk out of death
row
and believe in all of you
and yes the truth is
the 19 years that I have been free
have been harder than all the death row
days that I've done
that's incredible
it's more immediate
and profound
and Lasting the things that I've
encountered out here
people have been exceedingly cruel
without any punishment notion behind it
but
I've also found
there's so much Beauty and good out here
I have to continue believing it all has
meaning
because
I realized
the people I've given courage to
see me falter I steal from them the
grace that I've given them
I dare not do that
though I shared tears today they're
really just expressions of letting out
so much that I've waited three years to
talk about
I'm really honestly at this point
feeling like I can let all of this go
and if this is my last interview here in
the United States
I share a beautiful smile knowing that
it won't be sad and that things are
going to be better in the future
thank you for your time
I really am grateful goodbye and take
care
incredible story thank you